let's imagine that you're applying for a
job you know you want to be an assistant
professor
or let's suppose that you're seeking a
promotion
uh in on many University campuses you
are asked to give a Dei statement
in which you say
um I plan to you know you know one one
of the reasons why you should hire me or
one of the reasons why you should
promote me is because I'm going to you
know Advance the you know the Dei
uh Ambitions diversity equity and
inclusion for people don't know this is
the general uh set of programs uh that
most universities now have yes
that's right so you know you've got to
sort of
you know basically
which are being asked to do
whether they say it explicitly or not
they don't say this explicitly but this
is what they're being this is what is up
what you're being asked to do is to say
I'm down with
the diversity equity and inclusion
ethos program policy campaign
and here's what I've done that shows
that I'm down with this program
and therefore I'm okay
well you know a lot of what I do would
fit very comfortably within that but
let's suppose that I didn't just oppose
I didn't like this
and by the way there's certain aspects
of the Dei you know industry that I
don't like
you mean to tell me that uh you know I'm
being judged at an academic institution
let's suppose I want to be a chemist
let's suppose I want to be a physicist
let's suppose I want to be I don't care
uh you know a you know a Critic of
literature
uh I oppose this program I don't you
know I'm I I don't think this is the way
in which higher education should be
going
should I have to on pain of
relinquishing my ability to be hired
should I have to sign on to this uh just
suppose and let's change it around let's
not make it a Dei campaign let's make it
a makeup America great again campaign
what would we think then
let's suppose it was something that said
instead of it saying Dei let's make it
let's make it say
um the advancement of American
capitalism as we know it
we want you to be down with that what
have you done that shows us that you
believe in the advancement of capitalism
in America
would I be happy about no I would say
this is no
well no with respect to these as far as
I'm concerned
with the you know the Dei statements oh
here's another one
um I just learned and in fact I mean
there are certain things that are
happening
and I must say I mean I'm in Academia
but uh it's it's news to me I didn't
know no until relatively recently about
positionality statements
so these are statements in which
somebody writes an article
let's suppose you know I write an
article
and
um
it's not enough for me just to submit my
article to some law review or to some
you know some other sort of Journal
now in addition to me submitting My
article
I've got to give a a positionality
statement in which I say whether I am
you know gay or straight or whatever
what have you in which I say my race in
which I say my nationality in which I
say my you know my stance toward this
ideological position or that ideological
position
interesting what
is this uh uh becoming a
kind of a standard I don't know how
widespread it is I know there was a very
good article in the New York Times
uh a couple of days ago about these
positionality statements and in fact
that's what sort of tipped me off
somebody had told me there's a law
review at my home institution and I had
a friend
who sort of mentioned this offhandedly
and who said well I submitted an article
to this journal
and I was a little bit taken aback
insofar as
they did have me fill out a
questionnaire
in which in which
I was required
to State my race State this state that
state the other
and
you know
um
as far as I'm concerned well
what does that have to do
with
a proper assessment
of somebody's work
This concerns me
um I'm concerned about the fact you you
know a little while ago you mentioned
a little while ago you mentioned the
word negro
uh at I was talking with colleagues a
couple months ago and somebody mentioned
that
uh this word had come up in their class
because what had happened was
one student was
reading from a Supreme Court decision
and the word negro was part of what they
read out and another student held up his
hand
and said to the student who was reading
a you should be careful
because you know I find the word negro
offensive
and you need to be careful about even
saying a word
that would be offensive to someone and
this person and then you know the
teacher was you know well you know you
know what should I say in those
circumstances you know what should I
have said
and I volunteered you know and you know
and you know and I said well gosh that's
really interesting because see if that
had come up in my class
um I would have said well frankly I
don't you know I don't see what the the
I don't even see what the big deal is
because I use the word negro
and
um
you know uh Harvard University is not on
you know on some Island that is
you know apart from everything else is
happening in the world if these things
are happening in other places if they're
happening at Stanford if they're
happening at Yale if they're happening
at Columbia
uh you know they're gonna happen at
Harvard
um but thus far and I'm I'm I am most
especially
experienced in life at Harvard Law
School
Harvard Law School
Is An Open environment in which ideas
are tested
and they are tested fully
and uh it's it's it's because of that
that I say I have been fully supported
at Harvard Law School feel that it is an
excellent place in which to do work I'm
I'm a fan I am a fan and I'm not
embarrassed to say it I am a fan
of uh of my workplace Harvard Law School
I'm very happy to be associated with
Harper